d'où vient l'argent
le droit d'appeler eric woerth
alors d'où vient l'argent la deuxième
c'est qu'on associé cyril à l'argent et
à vous et versa je commence à savoir
d'où viendra
alors je le dis aux téléspectateurs on a
on y associe sur une boîte ensemble et
c'est vrai qu'ils travaillent
extrêmement bien je vais dire moi d'où
vient la guillaume c'est un très gros
bosseur il vend des choses sur plein de
chaînes y arrivant sur rmc story il ment
sur this évite canal+ ils vont sur
canal+ ils vont sceller sur quoi
installer france télévisions alors
les chaînons non voilà donc non mais
pour réponse c'est le plateau il va
donner vos activités parce que vous
n'êtes pas seulement coloriste
mois ses conseils vestimentaires je lis
beaucoup de tweets en disant que je suis
fils de que je suis bi stones etc déjà
j'ai plusieurs sociétés chez pas que la
télé bien sûr et je fais énormément de
choses moi-même serre que je fais du
montage et voix off c'est ça un faitout
je construis mes documentaires j'ai une
équipe et lui